JACKSON FROM DEEP.
AND THAT MIGHT DO IT.
JAZZ UP SEVEN.
BOGDANOVIC OVER TO INGLES.
TY LUE WANTS THEM TO FOUL.
AND WE HAVE WHAT LOOKS LIKE AN
EJECTION.
SCOTT FOSTER POINTED AT I THINK
REGGIE JACKSON.
>> Doris: I DON'T KNOW.
OR PAUL GEORGE.
THEY WERE ON THE GROUND, WAY
AWAY FROM THE PLAY, AND HE HIT
THE DECK.
AND HE'S IN SOME SERIOUS PAIN.
>> Mark:.
>> Mark: FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
MITCHELL FAVING THAT RIGHT LEG.
>> Doris: IS IT THE ANKLE?
>> Mark: REMEMBER, HE MISSED THE
THAT'S 16 GAMES OF THE REGULAR
SEASON WITH AN INJURY.
HE WAS FAVORING THAT RIGHT LEG
ON THE WAY DOWN.
>> Doris: FOUL CALL.
IT WAS SCOTT FOSTER BEING REALLY
DEMONSTRATIVE WITH THE CALL.
I SAW WHERE YOU WERE GOING WITH
IT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
DEMONSTRATIVE.
>> Mark: DONOVAN MITCHELL WITH
36 TONIGHT.
50 % FROM THE FIELD.
15 OF 29.
>> Doris: HE HAD 30 AT THE HALF.
27 THE FIRST HALF.
BUT MARK, TO PICK A POINT THAT'S
DIFFERENT -- THEY'RE DOUBLE TEAM
BECAME BETTER